à voir les champs on va les tirs et ont
attiré qui ont retiré qui chacun votre
tour vous allez venir tirer un sucre
d'orge ceux qui ont les sucres d'orge de
la même longueur seront ensemble dans la
chambre il y en a un petit peu plus
parce que il y aura des lipides qui
arrivera demain sucre d'orge qui restera
bien entendu
delphine sera dans la chambre avec celui
qui restera castaldi point de sucre
d'orge à d'un petit sucre d'or pour
l'instant les raccords belge il tire sur
sucre d'orge évidemment petit sucre
d'orge les sucres d'orge ne manque
jamais un mois je pense je vais tomber
sur un bâton de pèlerin célèbre est
logique il avait atteint grand sucre
d'orge
mathieu est ce que déjà tu vas aller
rejoindre ou castaldi ou isabelle morini
bosc
[Musique]
alors je suis je plus rentable plus
grand qu'à star kelly pas mal tepa est
en tout cas vous vous êtes dans quatre
chambres différentes
ces deux bonnes nouvelles déjà là ça y
est on va commencer à entrer
normalement on va voir que d'être la
première personne north bay maximum non
non non non à mr non alors maintenant
normalement
ou bien qu'on dit c'est pas possible
ou bien nous aide chacun et de quelqu'un
à saillé toi donc watts avec mon amie
mélanie car aux usa
mettez vous là bas
ils avaient été tués non mais c'est pas
possible quoi maxime et moi c'est le
pôle nord et le pôle sud pourquoi on
fait ça moi je viens gentiment en
laponie on me faut être maxime dans une
chambre non on a passé coup de bol les
losers aux sont entre curtis sucre
d'orge la vie bien fait il n'y a pas de
hasard surtout et donc ils restent
belles et meilleures benjamin jean
michel kelly
cyril et moi attention tu crois
peut-être que je me retrouve à ne
chanter que des films spider
elle arrive dans 24 heures mais ces
parages parce qu'est venu tout seul mais
je vais pouvoir chauffer le lit comme un
ouf et le mal va arriver tout sera
nickel avec matthew finnie out dès lé
film à temps je me retrouve avec mathieu
j'adore mathieu c'est pas le problème
mais enfin je passe d'un palace un gîte
une étoile voir une étoile moi c'est pas
pas de bol bien sûr j'y vais avec toi
gamme sont des trucs là abattu je
regarde regarde car je devrais peut-être
bien pour tout le monde franchement
c'est jeux de hasard
l'image ya pile
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment il n'est pas de hasard il
n'est que des rencontres etienne daho
cyril tire le même sucre d'orge que moi
voilà je pense qu'il ya un moment donné
on ne peut rien faire contre la fatalité
donc on va dormir ensemble oui non mais
là oui bah oui à noter dans ma chambre
donc moi je suis je donc moi je les deux
quarts de ces huit [ __ ] et de quoi
attirer problème c'est que moi je ne
peux pas être quelqu'un sache pourquoi
c'est un rapport à quoi le rapport à toi
rapport parce que non mais rapport à
l'hygiène
on peut l'écouter rapport à beaucoup
travailler ouais et fonctionnement
pourquoi on veut pour allumer tpn fait
des animaux si on écoute alors atone et
déjà on va finir ce tirage au sort cyril
commence à nouveau à ses règles
tunisienne quand ça lui convient pas je
vais dormir avec cyril puis avec
delphine plus avec personne je sens
polypes tous histoire je te réponds qu'à
l'âge de tir pour delphine bataille
finale presque peut-être que tu seras
tout son argent au canada voiture a pu
afficher leurs couleurs de la future
belle fille battue avec delphine ta
femme va être content mais ce plaisir
dans ma chambre c'est impossible mais
pourquoi banquette cas de divorce par un
cinquième gp les moyens voilà j'ai un
truc à te demander toi maintenant c'est
toi qui va choisir
ouais puisque toi aujourd'hui
star des civils tués non aujourd'hui il
reste deux personnes qui sont seules
dans la chambre ouais tu attires
hectares
est-ce que tu préfèrerais aller avec
quelqu'un qui est tout seul que toi oui
là ça nantes en a pas pourquoi pourquoi
pas ma foi alors et moi que tu fais pas
tu es sûr mais oui je ne contredis pas
le destin et moi je suis moi je posais
une question puisque jamais ni moi et
toi tu avec kita mais j'étais que
mathieu une avec toi maintenant vos
chèques d'un film moi j'ai une belle vie
moi même et avec des si voila voila
c'était joseph merci chef
bah ouais tu peux m'appeler des navettes
soit sauve tout seul voilà les mecs
c'est un bordel c'est pas un bordel on
est ensemble change pas les règles
les mecs je propose on va refaire
[Musique]
non
à
les mecs ça va être très simple voilà
les chambres on reprend depuis le début
non caroline is assez bon non c'est
maxime gilles c'est bon c'est bon
benjamin et avec delphine comme
commandes avaient tiré jean mythe avec
mathieu kelly en itinérance pour moi
seul est-ce qu'on est d'accord on a
réussi à régler ce problème le centre
est compliqué est ce que maintenant vous
avez envie de voir les chambres des sacs
en laponie
sachez qu'il ya eu voilà une
distribution de chambre ça a été fait
dans l'ordre
et quand les chambres ont été tirés et
un petit souci rassure il ya eu un petit
souci avec benjamin castaldi il ya eu le
malheur d'appeler sa femme en facetime
et il lui a annoncé la nouvelle
pour delphine et lui ou là ah oui vous
allez voir on est passé à ça du divorce
est vraiment et quand je dis à sa grâce
à elle était vraiment énervé raisonnable
est normal bah oui allez voir
franchement je ne comprends pas c'est
pas une question de jambes c'est une
question c'est ma vie
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous êtes là mes chéris tant que
c'est pas mal mais c'est très bien mais
non c'est une petite salle de bains elle
une petite douche l'économie aurait bien
voilà les choses je voulais ça il ya un
truc que tu me dire izard on sait je
sais pas non je ne fais pas un agent me
oui nature
excusez-nous pardon les regards les
chaumes ces rapports et audience j'en
avais je suis très franchement c'est pas
mon jeu mais oui oui à cannes ah ben
quand on n'est pas sûr qu'un type qui
aurait eu à widnes et mon jour me lâche
plus toi tu as une petite baignoire
je suis franchement vous n'êtes pas à
bâle au début on a des machines à tous
tu dois je vous laisse du coup la
chambre moi je n'ai plus belles chambres
de la maison via une baignoire un lit
double c'est plutôt une chambre de
lovers
ça aurait dû être celle que j'aurais pu
partager avec cyril sait-on jamais le
séjour est long je voudrais maximus
moshiri hills avec monchy vous d'amour
à doute pas recette
c'est pas la house mais beaucoup c'est
m'immiscer goncourt aller votre petite
salle de bain avec maxime kenny c'est
déjà un enfer et là je vois la chambre
mais là c'est le pompon dirait un cagibi
ou un truc de films d'horreur et va les
voir un meurtre avant la fin et ce sera
pas gagné le meurtrier faire une chance
c'est la vie mais ce ratio dans la
langue alors
mais ressemble à ces tâches banda s'est
trop mis à mais c'est trop dur aux mines
s'est rendu à temps pour la course hors
normes alors je découvre ma petite
chambre d'amour elle est juste mais
magnifique j'ai trop de la chance à
l'est rien que pour moi elle est
vraiment trop trop belle c'est allé trop
vite et bien lui sauver la mise
en gros c'est juste kelly au pays des
merveilles et du père noël
badji jeu car le la suite de la chambre
de castany avec la finale butin
c'est là bas c'est lâche c'est l'action
de la spa et les mecs ont refait mais
franchement entre la chambre pour il a
et biblis pont qu'il aura avec moi c'est
pas possible qu'il soit possible pour
une solution c'est pas possible pas
possible je me barre
[Musique]
un an
mais aussi évidemment propose une
solution de repli éventuel une chambre
qui est une chambre de passage qu'en
fait quand on veut faire du sport ou
passe dans ma chambre
limite on fait du sport en pierre au
pied de mon lit et au bout il ya le
salon et le sauna est partagé entre le
confort et la date exacte
moi tu sais quoi je suis un défenseur de
la carte de la barka maintenant tu vois
ici bas mais bon on attend avec quand
même un côté s'asséchant mai et ça ça
peut m'aider j'ai dans le but mais là tu
allégé dans le but confrères 4
la caution doit partir la consigne est
parti on continue tout le propriétaire
au sous sol ni à une chambre absolument
magnifique avec une salle de sport un
jacuzzi un sauna
en principe elle est dédiée à benji mais
s'il ne veut pas moi je suis à fond sur
le dos parce que la pression dans cette
suite parentale ou sentimental il ya
moyen de faire des mes petites conneries
comme une personne calme et voilà en
tout cas tout l'assortiment et ging
regarde mon jogging d'un jogging de
famille mon grand père me l'avait donné
à mon père je te faire quand tu me faire
coiffer rejet de voler à ne suffit de
merde
oh là là là regardez moi ça regardez moi
ça la balade s'est pas repreneur toi ma
mi temps qui courent je me dis si on
propose une plus belle chance et j'aurai
un peu suite un peu un peu sympa tout
c'est qu'il ya un piège bien c'est
encore une une ânerie ça voilà je me
méfie beaucoup je suis totalement
paranoïaque ici la chambre de la ce
personne d'une blague je fais pressée
témoin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]